probably not many members of the Miami
Dolphins on your fantasy team if there
are you probably didn't win week one and
you may want to trade or dump some of
those guys which is what some Dolphins
players want I reported on Sunday the
multiple players have reached out to
their agents and did so in the aftermath
of that 59 210 shellacking they took at
the hands of the Ravens said get me out
of here I don't want to be part of this
tank job and that's the perception it's
the perception on the outside Peter it's
the perception on the inside that the
Dolphins are tanking Brian Flor is the
head coach addressed it yesterday saying
I can't speak to the accuracy of that
report we haven't received any
information like that
I think for us we just need to focus on
what's going on within the building and
not worry about anything that's going on
outside okay fine what's going on in the
building Peter is guys can sense what
the Dolphins are doing and the guys who
aren't completely sure they're going to
be there for the rebuild want to get out
while they can is that wrong if you
sense that there's tanking going on Mike
one of the things that any football guy
will tell you any general manager any
coach is that this game is too hard it's
too rough it's too physical to enter a
game thinking that you're not really
trying to win because that just plays
with your head that's one of the reasons
why I can't believe how many people
either you know DM me or sent me a text
or said something on Twitter okay now
what could they get for the other guys
what could they get for xavie and Howard
what could they hey if somebody offers
the the Miami Dolphins seven first-round
picks for zaevion Howard you know Chris
Greer the general manager cannot take it
they can't dump any more players you
know onto this market right now because
they need to to to combat this
impression that we're not trying to win
this year it's going to be impossible to
do among any smart player but they need
they can't throw any more logs on that
fire so in my opinion yeah if the
Dolphins have brought this on themselves
by basically being all-in they got eight
picks in the first two rounds the next
two years I mean that's that's in
that's Browns like and you knew what the
Browns were trying to do yeah Mike I
don't blame players for like calling
their agents and going gosh if there's
an opportunity to get me out of here get
me out of here I understand that
especially for some of the older guys
that are in the locker room or aren't as
financially as secure as somebody like
Peters bringing up examine Howard who
they gave a huge contract to this
offseason because hey it's Brian Flores
and he wants somebody to be his Stephon
Gilmore right so that's where they
pegged him but I said I think the rest
of the team of course looks at the
recent moves and then goes oh man well
we're certainly not putting ourselves in
a position to win a football game you
know arguably the second-best playoff
football team Laremy Tunsil gets traded
you know with the Kenny Stills and I
don't even think that the Dolphins
really wanted to do that but I think
they got an offer that they just
couldn't refuse from the Houston Texans
and they are rebuilding and it makes
sense and I take Brian Flores at his
word I don't think he's heard any of
this like agents aren't calling him or
the Dolphins I don't think Mike unless
you think I'm wrong where they're just
going hey things don't look good here
you know my player doesn't want to play
can you try to trade them that just is
not gonna go down in the NFL so you know
it's gonna be more the thing where an
agent might call other teams and shop as
player and say hey you have any interest
here maybe you should call the Dolphins
my guy would love to get out of there
but I don't think it's gonna be anything
more than that just gonna be tough
sledding for those guys in Miami you
guys each mentions avian Howard I think
he's the one guy who is on top touch him
doesn't want to go he's gonna be there
he was the one who said last week we got
to trust the process trust the process
that's the NBA code for tanking right
trusting the process means oh we're
going to stink for a year or two but
eventually we're gonna be better
Howard's gonna be there but we know what
the turnover is in the NFL a lot of
these guys who are part of the process
now Peter there are gonna be somewhere
else if not out of football by the time
this comes to fruition Mike what the
Miami Dolphins have done what Chris
Greer has done what Steven Ross has
directed them to do is to make sure in
2020
you have your long-term quarterback of
the future what is happening is Justin
Herbert insurance everybody can see it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports